la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
intégral de la séance du jeudi 2 février
a été publié sur le site internet du
Sénat il n'y a pas d'observation le
procès-verbal est adopté
la parole est à Monsieur gold pour une
mise au point au sujet de plusieurs
votes oui merci madame la Présidente
alors lors du scrutin 122 portant sur
l'article 1 de la proposition de loi
visant à habilité les militaires
fusillés pour l'exemple durant la
Première Guerre mondiale Bernard fialer
aurait souhaité voter pour par ailleurs
lors du scrutin 123 portant sur
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
visant à protéger les logements contre
l'occupation illicite Guylaine Pantel
Jean-Pierre corbizet rigolt était
s'abstenir
merci acte et donner de ces mises au
point elles seront publiées au Journal
officiel et figureront dans l'analyse
politique des scrutin concernés mes
chers collègues la Conférence des
Présidents inscrit le prochain débat
d'actualité à l'ordre du jour du
mercredi 8 février à 16h30 après
concertation avec les groupes politiques
ce débat porterait sur proposition du
président du Sénat sur le thème suivant
quelle réponse européenne au récentes
mesures protectionnistes américaines
sous forme de discussion générale d'une
heure y a-t-il des observations il en
est ainsi décidé
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen de la
proposition de résolution exprimant le
soutien du Sénat à l'Ukraine condamnant
la guerre d'agression menée par la
Fédération de Russie et appelant au
renforcement de l'aide fournie à
l'Ukraine présentée en application de
l'article 34-1 de la Constitution par
Monsieur Claude malurey dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Claude malurey auteur de la
proposition de résolution et pour 10
minutes chers collègues
je voudrais tout le voir remercier les
présidents de groupe et les très
nombreux sénateurs qui ont décidé de
consigner cette proposition de
résolution remercier également le
président du Sénat qui lui confère une
solennité particulière en demandant
lui-même son inscription à l'ordre du
jour du Sénat
un an après l'invasion de l'Ukraine nous
avons appris plusieurs leçons
fondamental la première est l'ampleur
des mensonges que le Kremlin a orchestré
sans relâche depuis des années pour
justifier ses agressions successives
l'Occident est responsable de tout le
temps menace la Russie soutient des
nazis et des criminels de guerre
multiplient les provocations l'Europe et
le valet de l'impérialisme américain ces
discours délirants relayés avec
constance par le parti prorus en Europe
ont trompé beaucoup de monde ils ont
volé en éclat le jour où de juin dernier
à Saint-Pétersbourg ou Poutine lui-même
a fini par avouer ce qu'il pense depuis
toujours l'Ukraine et russe et comme
autant de Pierre Legrand la Russie va
reprendre par la guerre ces territoires
perdus balayer la propagande balayer
tous les mensonges balayer la fable de
l'Occident menaçant empire colonial sous
les tsar la Russie fait le dernier
empire colonial sur le communisme après
la fin des empires anglais et français
elle veut le redevenir et l'on comprend
aujourd'hui le sens de la phrase
prononcée par Poutine en 2005 la chute
de l'URSS fut lu la plus grande
catastrophe politique du 20e siècle
parce que la chute de l'URSS c'était la
fin de l'Empire russe
la deuxième leçon de cette guerre et que
l'ampleur de ces mensonges n'a eu d'égal
que l'ampleur de nos illusions et de nos
lâchetés ce n'est pas l'agressivité de
l'Occident qui a conduit Poutine à
envahir l'Ukraine c'est sa passivité en
2008 les leaders européens ont refusé à
l'Ukraine et à la Géorgie l'adhésion à
l'OTAN pour ne pas irriter Poutine
quelques mois plus tard il envahissait
la Géorgie quand il a envahi la Crimée
nous avons un nouveau répondu avec des
sanctions bien modestes il est clair que
les craintes infondées de provoquer
Poutine en le convainquant de notre
faiblesse ont ouvert la voie à
l'invasion totale de 2022
cette erreur majeure d'analyse fut
d'abord celle de l'Allemagne et de la
France depuis 30 ans la politique
allemande défendait sur la dépendance
énergétique à la Russie la dépendance
commerciale à la Chine et le désarmement
face aux deux celle de la France fut de
courtiser la Russie pour trianguler sa
relation avec les États-Unis en espérant
acquérir une position indépendante sans
en avoir les moyens politiques et
militaires que signifie puissance
d'équilibre quand il y a d'un côté une
démocratie qui est neutraliée depuis
plus de deux siècles qui nous a sauvés
lors de deux guerres mondiales et nous a
évité de devenir la province occidentale
du rail allemand ou de l'Union
soviétique et de l'autre une
cryptocratie mafieuse qui succède à un
régime totalitaire ayant asservi
l'Europe pendant des décennies
les avertissements répétés des Européens
de l'Est qui savent eux ce que c'est que
l'impérialisme russe ont été rejetés
avec mépris comme des agitations de
vattes en guerre hystérique l'invasion
de l'Ukraine nous montre l'échec de ces
deux politiques et surtout l'urgence à
ne pas les poursuivre l'apaisement et le
compromis avec un dictateur n'ont jamais
marché le dictateur avance devant la
faiblesse et recule devant la force
c'est aussi simple que ça depuis
toujours si l'Europe est une paix
durable sur le continent elle doit
apprendre le langage de la puissance le
seul que les dictateurs comprennent la
troisième leçon est le degré de nuisance
de bassesse et de complicité du parti
prorus en Europe et particulièrement en
France cette cinquième colonne des
extrémistes qui cherchent sans relâche à
nous désarmer face à un loup qu'il
présente comme un mouton qui depuis des
années nous répète que Poutine est le
plus grand dirigeant du monde qui
reprennent notamment sur les réseaux
antisociaux avec les milliers de faux
comptes de trolls et de bottes pilotés
depuis Moscou sur pour les télé RT et
d'autres la propagande de Poutine
l'Ukraine n'existe pas elle est russe
ses dirigeants sont des nazis Pouchkine
le grand poétrus disait qu'on nous donne
une auge nous trouverons les cochons ils
sont la boussole qui indiquent sans
jamais se tromper la direction du
déshonneur par le chemin le plus sordide
depuis l'invasion de l'Ukraine Le Pen la
baronnette des guichets de Moscou et
Mélenchon le génufleteur des plus
infâmes dictatures condamne du bout des
lèvres car ne pas le faire serait un
suicide mais il ne change pas d'avis
tout est de la faute de l'Occident
surtout pas d'armes surtout pas de
sanction leur députés européens ont
refusé de voter même l'aide humanitaire
à l'Ukraine leur parlementaire français
ont refusé de voter l'entraide la Suède
et de la Finlande dans l'OTAN lors du
discours du président de la Rada
ukrainienne à l'Assemblée mardi dernier
ils ont déserté l'hémicycle pendant que
tous leurs collègues étaient debouts
pour l'applaudir n'écoutez pas ce que
disent les dirigeants des parties de la
France russe regardez leur vote regardez
leurs gestes et vous comprendrez qu'ils
n'ont rien lâché qui sont toujours en
embuscade comme des crapauds blottis
sous une grosse pierre en attendant que
passe l'orage que faire aujourd'hui
d'abord tirer les leçons de nos erreurs
passées car nous ne les en avons pas
toutes tirer nous nous félicitons à
juste titre que l'Europe ne soit pas
divisée comme l'espérée Poutine mais
unis que notre alliance avec les
États-Unis et les autres démocraties se
soient renforcées que le soutien à
l'Ukraine reste constant que les
opinions publiques horrifiées par les
crimes de guerre et les crimes contre
l'humanité chaque jour sur leurs écrans
tiennent bon mais attention les
différences d'appréciations entre
européen de l'Ouest et européen de l'Est
et du Nord n'ont pas disparu et chaque
étape du conflit voit réapparaître
l'écart entre ceux qui se qualifient de
réalisme entre guillemets et ceux qui
veulent aller plus loin et plus vite les
réalistes ne craignent l'escalade ils
pensent qu'il y a des lignes rouges à ne
pas franchir chaque épisode de cette
guerre prouve qu'ils ont tort en
refusant l'escalade ils en laissent le
monopole à Poutine et font perdre à
chaque fois les semaines nécessaires à
la contre-offensive c'est semaine c'est
moi parfois ce sont des milliers du
crinien qui meurent les lignes rouges
nous savons désormais qu'elles ne sont
que le fruit de nos peurs chaque fois
que Poutine les traces et qu'elles sont
franchies ils ne se passent rien comment
pourrait-il frapper plus fort alors que
son armée minée par la corruption qui
ronge son matériel l'incompétence de ces
chefs et la défiance de ces soldats est
déjà au-delà de son maximum et paralysé
sur tous les fronts quant à la rengaine
du danger nucléaire Poutine laisse
désormais mettre vedef le pochard et la
broff le croque-mort les brandir sur les
plateaux des traces télé de Moscou il a
compris depuis la mortifiante réunion de
Samarcande
ucci et maudit l'ont mis publiquement en
piqué qu'elle lui est interdite même
parmi ces peines par ses propres alliés
cessons de nous faire peur avec ce
disque rayé depuis 50 ans le but n'est
pas de permettre à l'Ukraine de résister
mais de chasser l'occupant si nous
avions livré dès le début ce que nous
nous apprêtons à livrer aujourd'hui
l'Ukraine n'aurait pas seulement
reconquis car qui véherson mais
largement profité dans le longbase
profitant de la déroute russe ce sera
bien plus difficile maintenant quand
leur a laissé le temps de se retrancher
mais c'est néanmoins un bon signe que de
plus en plus de dirigeants européens
hier dans le camp des réalistes soient
en train de comprendre que la livraison
massive d'armes n'aurait pas eu pour
conséquence de prolonger la guerre mais
au contraire de l'écourter par la
débâcle des envahisseur
mieux vaut tard que jamais c'est
maintenant qu'il faut livrer les chars
les missiles les défenses solaires et
les avions si nous voulons comme le
Prométhée le président de la République
lors de ses vœux accompagner l'Ukraine
jusqu'à la victoire finale
il est enfin une dernière raison encore
plus essentielle de ne pas répéter les
erreurs du passé les démocraties au
terme d'une lutte implacable ont vaincu
au 20e siècle les deux totalitarismes
aux dizaines de millions de morts
certains les croyaient disparus à jamais
sous nos yeux l'international des tyrans
se reforment le boucher de Moscou le
génocidaire des Ouigours en Chine le
Docteur Folamour de Corée du Nord le
massacreur de femmes de Téhéran et
quelques autres se sont regroupés leur
seul but se venger abattre l'Occident
mettra-bas la liberté la deuxième guerre
froide a commencé et depuis plusieurs
années beaucoup de dirigeants
occidentaux proclament que nous ne
sommes pas en guerre contre la Russie
j’espoir bien que ce discours n'est que
tactique et qu'il n'en croit pas un mot
parce que les dictateur eux l'annonce
clairement ils sont en guerre contre
nous
ils veulent achever les démocraties
qu'ils croient agonisantes il n'y aurait
rien de pire que de croire que nous ne
sommes pas en guerre contre des gens qui
sont en guerre contre nous et qui le
disent quand on reste du monde il attend
l'issue du conflit pour voler au secours
de la victoire ce qui en espéraient une
certaine sympathie se trompe lourdement
les dirigeants bien peu démocratiques de
la plupart de ces pays se moquent de
savoir si Poutine a violé les lois
internationales ils ont même pour mantra
la justification de leur méfaits actuels
par la condamnation de notre domination
passée l'Europe doit comprendre
l'urgence de redevenir une puissance
militaire d'avoir une stratégie commune
et de consolider notre alliance avec les
autres démocraties du monde a commencé
par les États-Unis si nous n'y arrivons
pas
si nous laissons les cinquième colonnes
des fachos des trots des populistes et
des idiots utiles nous conduire à
l'aveuglement et aux renoncement alors
ce n'est pas seulement l'Ukraine demain
qui sera vaincu mais la liberté il est
temps de réarmer les démocraties face au
tyrannie du 21e siècle le peuple
héroïque du crâne nous en montre le
chemin je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Grand pour le groupe les indépendants
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues sidéré par
la brutalité des événements du crâne
depuis le 24 février dernier nous nous
devons de garder la mémoire du temps
long pour en saisir le sens et la portée
sachant ne pas oublier la longue période
de dictature et d'oppression du régime
communiste dans l'URSS alors et
l'enfermement de ce régime dans une
confrontation toujours plus acharnée
sachant ne pas oublier ce qu'on
signifier la chute du mur de Berlin et
la partition de son empire source de
nostalgie de ressentiment parmi les
dirigeants et ses forces armées Vladimir
Poutine n'a jamais fait mystère de ses
sentiments sur cette page d'histoire qui
l'a rappelé en 2005 la plus grande
catastrophe géopolitique du 20e siècle
les frontières de la Russie ils
s'inscrire dans l'histoire comme le
dirigeant qui lavera les affranchs de
l'histoire contemporaine à son pays
c'est son obsession en 2008 Vladimir
Poutine a jeté son dévolu sur le SETI la
famille en Géorgie et 6 ans plus tard
sur le don de base et la Crimée le 24
février dernier l'emballement de
l'histoire nous rappela que la Russie
n'avait pas renoncé à conquérir
l'Ukraine dans l'esprit des
nationalistes russes une victoire
militaire en quelques semaines contre
l'Ukraine ce serait traduite par un
triangle de la ligne routine
dans cet esprit Poutine tente
aujourd'hui de réhabiliter Staline pour
remotiver un nationalisme russe
confronté au doute que lui inspire les
revers de l'armée russe la réalité est
bien là la Russie est loin d'avoir pu
conquérir l'Ukraine et remplacer le
gouvernement de Kiev la lumière Poutine
a sous-estimer la réaction occidentale
et en particulier la capacité de l'Union
européenne d'organiser son unité pour
porter secours à une nation voisine
envahie
les États-Unis par leur envoi massif
d'équipement militaire leur aide
financière affiche leur soutien moral et
politique à l'Ukraine Vladimir Poutine
et ses généraux ont sous-estimé la force
du patriotisme du peuple ukrainien ses
capacités militaires tactiques
mécaniques et bien sûr le courage la
force politique du président zeninski
qui a su mobiliser son peuple et obtenir
le soutien d'une d'un grand nombre de
démocratie mes chers collègues l'indici
de cette guerre s’écrime sa barbarie ses
milliers et milliers de morts la
déportation de citoyens et même
d'enfants tout cela l'histoire ne
l'oubliera pas tôt ou tard les
dirigeants russes devront rendre compte
mais aujourd'hui chaque Français
voudrait voir cesser cette guerre aux
conséquences désormais ressenties dans
leur vie quotidienne monsieur le
ministre
beaucoup s'interrogent sur le rôle de la
France
ici au Sénat nous savons que la France
plus qu'on est que notre pays a
conscience que son soutien sans réserve
à l'Ukraine ne la dispense pas au
contraire l'oblige à maintenir une
action diplomatique ambitieuse et dans
un même temps à livrer de l'armement aux
Ukrainiens et en plus sécurisé sa
présence sur tous les continents la
France dans l'engagement pour la paix
n'est plus à démontrer seul État de
l'Union européenne à disposer d'un siège
au Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU se doit
de développer une diplomatie de temps de
guerre c'est sa ligne politique de
toujours
la France voit de la paix c'est
anticiper les cataclysmes souvenons-nous
il y a 20 ans presque jour pour jour de
la position de Jacques Chirac et du
discours Dominique de Villepin à l'ONU
contre la guerre en Irak le message de
la supériorité du droit sur la force
reste plus que jamais d'actualité
aujourd'hui qui peut imaginer que le
Président de la République sa ministre
des Affaires étrangères et notre
diplomatie ne sont pas de la même
stratégie de lucidité pour aider à jeter
les bases d'une paix durable en Ukraine
sans renier ou affaiblir le soutien
occidental à cette nation martyre et
encore moins l'amener à renoncer à ses
frontières reconnues par l'ONU par les
Nations Unies cette salière menée par la
Russie s'étend aussi dans le même temps
auprès des pays émergents dont les
peuples vivants de la pauvreté sont une
proie facile pour Vladimir Poutine et sa
milice Wagner
les récents coups d'État militaires en
Afrique facilite le retournement contre
la France des populations abusées une
déstabilisation de l'Afrique conduira
mécaniquement à l'exode de ces
populations vers le continent européen
voilà une arme redoutable imaginée par
le Kremlin pour déstabiliser l'Europe
déstabiliser la France pour l'Afrique
pour déstabiliser l'Europe c'est aussi
cela la guerre que nous mène la lumière
Poutine enfin une autre conséquence de
la guerre à l'Ukraine et la stratégie
russe que la France doit gérer avec ses
partenaires dans sa diversité sa
complexité c'est le risque du retour
d'un sentiment politique quand on
l'Occident qui ne manquera pas là aussi
de créer de multiples problèmes de tous
ordres aux quatre coins du monde des
alliances improbables il y a encore
quelques mois j'ai presque fini une
réalité dès lors qu'elle servirait les
intérêts de la nation voilà quelques
raisons mes chers collègues qui forment
notre détermination à soutenir l'Ukraine
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Guillaume Gontard pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire pour 5
minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il y a près
d'un an jour pour jour vladivir Poutine
plongez l'Europe et le monde dans le
chaos en agressant son voisin ukrainien
un an plus tard le bilan de cette
invasion devenu une guerre de tranchée
d'un autre âge et terrifiant alors que
les soldats se battent dans la neige et
le froid glacial de l'hiver continental
le conflit aurait déjà fait plusieurs
centaines de milliers de victimes dans
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de civils
ukrainienne et ukrainien
la Russie qualifiée par le Parlement
européen d'État promouvant le terrorisme
devra répondre de ces crimes qu'il ne
soit permis à cette tribune de
renouveler au peuple ukrainien notre
hommage le plus vibrant et notre
admiration devant l'immense courage qui
est le sien nous admirons tant le
courage des militaires qui défendent la
ligne de front pièce à pied face aux
vagues des malheureux construits russes
envoyés à la mort que le courage des
civils vivant à l'arrière sous la menace
des bombes et des drones qui prennent
des vies et détruisent des
infrastructures civiles pour plonger le
pays dans le noir le froid la soif et la
solitude de l'hiver
un an plus tard le bilan de cette guerre
est déjà planétaire crise énergétique
inflation pénurie alimentaire l'économie
mondiale qui était à peine sortie de la
pandémie de covid-19 et de nouveau
plongée la tête sous l'eau les
perspectives à court terme sont
alarmantes le Programme Alimentaire
Mondial des Nations Unies considère que
nous sommes face à leur pire crise
alimentaire depuis la fin de la
troisième guerre mondiale plus que
jamais nos efforts de coopération
doivent être décuplés pour éviter de
mettre sur les routes des millions
d'affamés
un an plus tard nous remercions le
groupe Les Indépendants liberté et
territoires et son président Claude
maluré même avec certaines de ces
outrances déplacées de proposer à notre
examen cette proposition de résolution
pour exprimer le soutien du Sénat à
l'Ukraine cette guerre a trop durée nous
devons tout faire pour atteindre son
terme cela passe à par un renforcement
du soutien à l'Ukraine pour lui
permettre de repousser l'envahisseur
russe et de recouvrer ses frontières de
1991 on peut légitimement s'en inquiéter
et le déplorer mais aucune autre
alternative n'est sur la table la France
recevait la semaine dernière monsieur
rousselens Stéphane Tchouk président le
Rada qui nous a présenté la situation
suivante soit nous livrons à l'Ukraine
davantage d'armement de pointe pour lui
permettre de percer à nouveau le front
et d'avancer vers l'Est soit la guerre
va inévitablement s'enliser dans un
mercurier conflit de tranchées ou
périront tant de soldats que la Russie a
en nombre supérieur
si cette guerre s'étire sur plusieurs
années les conséquences seront
désastreuses pour l'Ukraine et pour le
monde entier aussi nous sommes
favorables à ce que la France et ses
alliés renforce leurs efforts en matière
de soutien militaire financiers et de
ravitaillement à ce titre nous demandons
solennellement au président de la
République de livrer quelques chars à
l'Ukraine au-delà de son efficacité
militaire que nous savons limiter cette
décision est indispensable politiquement
elle doit garantir à nos alliés que la
France est à leur côté dans toutes les
décisions importantes que cette guerre
exige de nous dès à présent se posera la
question de la fourniture d'avion de
chasse demandée par le président zen ski
la plus épineuse à ce jour ayant
constaté le grand sang-froid dans font
preuve le pouvoir politique et
l'état-major ukrainien nous croyons
possibles de fournir collectivement des
chasseurs à l'Ukraine sans risquer de
les voir utiliser à d'autres fins que la
défense de son territoire aussi nous
invitons les part
entamé pardon des discussions en ce sens
nous saluons le nouveau paquet de
sanctions annoncé par la présidente de
la Commission européenne et nous
appelons comme le demande le président
ukrainien ayant inclure les dirigeants
de rosatum à défaut de pouvoir nous
passer de l'uranium enrichi en Russie
pour notre fourniture électrique nous
saluons la décision historique de la
Norvège d'allouer une aide plus réelle
de près de 7 milliards d'euros à
l'Ukraine tant pour le soutien immédiat
au pays que pour sa reconstruction
future et nous invitons la France et
l'Union européenne à agir dans le même
sens cela doit aussi inclure une aide de
matériel au besoin logistiques immédiat
notamment l'envoi de groupe électrogène
enfin pour finir sur une perspective
optimiste nous saluons les progrès
réalisés par l'Ukraine dans son chemin
vers l'adhésion à l'Union chemin que
nous souhaitons le plus court possible
l’une des causes de ce conflit c'est
justement la volonté de l'Ukraine de
rejoindre l'Europe comme nous l'avons
été depuis un an nous devons nous devons
d'être indéfectiblement à la hauteur de
cette idéale de liberté et de démocratie
que des flancs le peuple
ukrainien voilà mes chers collègues nous
adopterons naturellement cette
résolution et souhaitons que le vote de
notre assemblée soit une anime merci
merci ce président la parole est à
Monsieur André gatolin pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistesait indépendants pour 6
minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en
préambule à mon propos je veux tout
d'abord remercier très chaleureusement
notre collègue Claude malurey qui a
porté cette initiative nous connaissons
tous ici sa vigilance de longue date à
l'endroit du régime de Vladimir Poutine
les propos ferment et constants qu'il
tient à ce sujet ici au Sénat depuis
2014 l'honneur et indirectement honore
notre assemblée au-delà je tiens
également à saluer l'ampleur du soutien
qui s'est déjà exprimé en faveur de
cette proposition de résolution et en
particulier son caractère éminemment
transpartisan puisque pas moins de 5
présidents de groupe sont qu'aux
signataires ce quasi consensus est
d'autant plus remarquable que les termes
employés par cette proposition sont
fermes précis et sans équivoque c'est il
est vrai le moins que nous puissions
faire face à cette agression horrible
perpétrée à l'encontre de l'Ukraine
cette guerre hybride
ukrainiennes sont sur la défensive tant
les moyens humains déployés par la
Russie sont importants les moyens
militaires de l'Ukraine en dépit de
l'aide prodigués sont insuffisants pour
tenir sérieusement une ligne de front
qui à l'est s'étend sur plus de 1500 km
et à laquelle il faut bien sûr ajouter
les 900 km de frontières avec la
Biélorussie ou le régime de Monsieur
Loukachenko définitivement vastalisée
par le Kremlin fait figure de complices
de celui-ci condamné fermement
l'attitude de la Russie qui dans tous
les domaines rond avec le droit
international le droit humanitaire et le
droit de la guerre est indispensable
Alexandra m'a dit chouk présidente du
centre des libertés civiques déclarait
il y a dix jours devant l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe que
son organisation je rappelle lauréate du
prix Nobel de la paix en 2022 avait
censé documenté plus de 31
000 crimes de guerre perpétrée par les
troupes russes et encore ne s'agit-il là
que des crimes possiblement responsables
car il en est certain dans les
territoires de l'est de l'Ukraine
annexée ou occupé par la Russie qui ne
peuvent être ni documentés ni
précisément quantifier c'est la raison
sans doute pour laquelle on déplie de
leur extrême gravité plusieurs de ses
crimes sont si elliptiquement évoqués
dans cette résolution je pense en
particulier à la situation de centaines
de milliers d'enfants qui ont été
déplacés de force vers le territoire
russe ils ont le mot c'est bien une
déportation de masse sans précédentes en
Europe depuis la Seconde la guerre
mondiale qui est à l'oeuvre les médias
propagandistes russes regorgent le
reportage louange c'était l'an de
soi-disant solidarité humanitaire de
famille riche qui adopte spontanément
ces pauvres orphelins de guerre
orphelins qui en réalité disposent
souvent au corps de parents en Ukraine
en fait et le Kremlin ne s'engage hier
il procède à ce qu'il appelle la
dénazification des territoires occupés
en désucrinisant les déportés en
procédant à leur rucification portée à
travers leurs changements de nom voire
même d'origine à l'état civil bien plus
qu'une épuration ethnique constitutive
en soi déjà d'un crime contre l'humanité
ce procédé honteux visantait éradiquer
l'identité d'enfants et aller prendre en
otage s'apparente un acte constitutif
d'un véritable génocide aussi au-delà de
cette résolution en faveur de laquelle
mon groupe le groupe RDPI se prononcera
unan je voudrais conclure mon propos en
interpellant notre haute assemblée sur
une question qui jusqu'à présent
Lagerfel objet de son attention on le
sait Rome ne sait pas construite en un
jour le pouvoir autoritaire de Vladimir
Poutine non plus son attitude n'a pas
soudainement basculé dans la nuit du 23
au 24 février 2022 qui est entraîné son
pays dans cette guerre un diable depuis
15 ans au moins des signes
avant-coureurs jalonné de sang
préfigurait déjà les charniers que nous
commençons à déterrer aujourd'hui
pourquoi n'avons pas vu venir cette
guerre et la dérive démocratique est
bellicise de son principal artisan
avons-nous été aveuglé où nous sommes
nous laissés aveugler l'argument de
l'imprésivie imprévisibilité et de
l'iranalité supposée de Vladimir poutur
Poutine à Bondo pour expliquer les
erreurs d'analyse stratégiques nous
avons commises alors ou de multiples
travaux de retours d'expérience sur
cette guerre sont engagés je crois qu'un
peu d'introspection sur nos faiblesses
passées ici ne serait sans doute pas
inutile je vous remercie de votre
attention merci chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur le président
c'est
République
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
voilà 349 jours la Fédération de Russie
a décidé sur ordre de son président
Poutine l'invasion d'un autre pays
souverain l'Ukraine en violation du
droit international cela fait 349 jours
qu'un peuple souffre cela fait 349 jours
qu'un peuple est bombardé cela fait 349
jours qu'un peuple se bat pour sa
liberté et au travers de ses libertés la
nôtre
au Sénat depuis presque un an nous avons
suivi l'évolution de la situation et
nous sommes réunis nous nous sommes
réunis de multiples reprises encore la
semaine dernière nous avons entendu les
mots
forts du président de la radar rosslan
Stéphane chou qui disait
on nous tue par le froid et l'obscurité
et un autre moment de la journée il nous
avait dit la Russie a volé un an de la
vie de l'Ukraine
ces mots ne peuvent pas rester sans écho
et je salue donc l'initiative du
président du groupe Les Indépendants
liberté et territoires qui a initié
cette proposition de résolution elle
nous permet en premier lieu de regarder
derrière nous et de tirer un premier
bilan de cette année de guerre en Europe
afin de tracer les perspectives qui
devront conduire vers une paix
victorieuse pour l'Ukraine et les
Ukrainiens
le 26 octobre dernier nous avons eu un
débat très riche très fort nous avons
condamné
dénoncer cette invasion et ses
conséquences notamment à l'égard des
populations civiles nous avons condamné
une invasion et des exactions contraires
au droit international nous n'oublierons
pas boutcha irpin Mario Paul et toutes
les autres villes martyrs nous sommes
inquiétés les conséquences collatérales
pour l'Europe et pour le monde
particulièrement en matière d'énergie et
de sécurité alimentaire nous nous sommes
interrogés sur les risques d'usure que
fait peser cette guerre une usure qui
pourrait atteindre la solidarité le
soutien des pays et de leurs concitoyens
à la cause de l'Ukraine
ces quelques mois qui nous séparent de
ce dernier débat permettent de faire un
certain nombre de constats et de tirer
quelques leçons
le premier de ces constat est que le
soutien à l'Ukraine reste non seulement
indéfectible mais il se renforce dans
l'opinion malgré l'inflation malgré les
coûts de l'énergie nos concitoyens n'ont
pas fléchi et l'adhésion à l'Union
européenne c'est même renforcée les pays
européens les Alliés ont seulement
continué à faire preuve de solidarité
mais il ne cesse de renforcer leur aide
qu'elle soit financières militaires ou
diplomatique et l'Union européenne a su
démontrer ses capacités de ressources
pour affronter les turbulences nous ne
devons pas relâcher l'effort et
continuer à relever collectivement
certains défis qui n'ont pas encore été
traités j'y reviendrai
le second constat et que le soutien en
termes de matériel notamment à produit
les effets l’armée ukrainienne a pu
mettre à son actif une reconquête d'une
partie de ces territoires l'armée russe
détenait 24,4% du territoire ukrainien
en mars 2022 aujourd'hui l'on contrôle
plus que 18 %. ces modestes mais c'est
une avancée les premiers responsables en
sont bien sûr les Ukrainiens dont le
courage et la compagnie la combativité
continue aujourd'hui d'être à l'oeuvre
sur les différents fronts on pense
notamment à baroute où les combats sont
particulièrement violents et à d'autres
zones où la situation reste très fragile
enfin l'escalade de t'empreinte n'a pas
eu lieu en tout cas pas sous la forme
que certains prédisaient la seule
escalade que l'on observe et celle de la
violence utilisée par l'armée russe à
l'encontre du peuple ukrainien en effet
nous avons changé nous avons observé un
changement de nature de la stratégie
russe qui s'est mise à cibler
délibérément systématiquement les
infrastructures critiques
ukrainien et les populations civiles
dans une fuite en avant à caractère
mortifère contraire à toutes les lois
cette stratégie ne peut que renforcer
notre détermination à nous tenir aux
côtés des Ukrainiens alors oui les
infrastructures nous aiderons à les
reconstruire alors oui les populations
nous continuerons à les soutenir et je
réussis une pensée mes chers collègues
pour les Français qui sont encore en
Ukraine certains dans l'est du pays sous
les bombes notamment à carquif ils ne
sont pas partis car leur vie est là-bas
leur attache familiale sont là-bas
certains n'ont pas les capacités
financières pour partir et les contacts
nécessaires en France pour le faire il
ne faut pas les oublier monsieur le
ministre et à leur côté pour répondre à
leurs éventuels demandent
cette résolution nous amène à nous
interroger sur les prochaines étapes
nécessaires pour aboutir à sortir de ce
conflit
personne sur ces banques comme partout
ailleurs personne ne veut la guerre
nous recherchons le retour à une
situation passifiée mais nous devons
être clair sur un point quitte à nous
répéter et à nous répéter nous ne
pouvons viser autre chose que la
victoire de l'Ukraine sur son agresseur
russe je l'ai déjà dit ici je le répète
aucun traité ne serait être arraché par
la force c'est d'égal à égal sous la
protection de l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale rassemblée au
sein de l'ONU que l'Ukraine et la
Fédération de Russie doivent définir les
modalités de leur coexistence même si
nous savons quelle sera difficile
notamment dans les premiers temps une
fois nous l'espérons la paix retrouver
car tout démontre que c'est dans un
rapport de force y compris militaire
avec Poutine que la voix de la
diplomatie pourrait être pour être
pardon retrouvé lui seul nous oblige à
réagir ainsi ne l'oublions pas pour
atteindre ce but
il convient de saluer le saut qualitatif
de l'aide militaire des chars seront
fournis
avec le temps nécessaire pour cette
livraison ils seront un renfort de poids
pour la l'armée ukrainienne des avions
pour l'être également la stratégie
ukrainienne reste et doit rester une
stratégie défensive que nous devons
soutenir par ses moyens elle l'a
toujours été parce que c'est l'Ukraine
qui est la nation agressée et c'est
l'Ukraine qui doit pouvoir se défendre
un renfort d'autant plus nécessaire que
la Russie a des ressources que ce soit
en termes de matériel comme de soldats
on ne connaît pas encore les effets de
la massification de son armée sur une
éventuelle future offensive à la fin de
l'hiver ou au début du printemps
comment depuis le début de la guerre
l'aide européenne doit être combiné avec
des sanctions pour l'économie russe il
convient de saluer le nouveau paquet de
sanctions annoncé par Ursula vanderleyen
pour le 24 février prochain date
anniversaire entre guillemets si l'on
peut dire de l'invasion dans ce cadre la
résolution site notamment la Biélorussie
qui fait partie de l'équation n'oublions
pas non plus cet état vassal du régime
de Moscou et ayant une pensée pour les
opposants biélorusses emprisonnés ou
exilés
comme le texte l'évoque nous devons
combiner notre action avec une réflexion
plus poussée qui pourra aboutir à des
enquêtes sur des faits susceptiques de
constituer des crimes de guerre des
crimes contre l'humanité l'Europe
travaille sur différentes pistes en ce
sens la France monsieur le ministre
devra prendre toute sa part dans ce
cadre
la guerre nous oblige à l'humilité comme
la résolution nous y invite plusieurs
questions restent à trancher au niveau
français à l'échelle européenne et au
sein de l'OTAN et je voudrais les
partager avec vous mes chers collègues
comment établir le basculement
stratégique comment reprendre l'avantage
dans le cadre d'une stratégie défensive
comment reconstruire l'Ukraine sur ce
dernier point la France devra y
participer au côté de ses partenaires à
ce stade le classement zone rouge de
l'ensemble de l'Ukraine par le ministère
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
empêche les entreprises françaises d'y
participer il faudra y travailler
cette humilité nous devons également
l'appliquer à la France cette guerre
interroge nos certitudes et nous devons
dès aujourd'hui dès aujourd'hui
réfléchir ensemble sur les capacités
militaires qui nous permettent de
protéger notre pays sur la réaffirmation
dans notre place dans l'OTAN sur la
place de la France sur le continent
européen et au niveau international ou
encore sur nos capacités économiques et
industrielles cette réflexion doit
s'inscrire à l'échelon national mais
aussi dans le cadre européen ce sont des
chantiers importants mes chers collègues
pour conclure nous ne devons pas
craindre Vladimir Poutine
quand celui-ci souligne qu'à travers
l'Ukraine il fait la guerre à l'Occident
monsieur Poutine est un prédateur il
profitera de chacune de nos faiblesses
et ces provocations verbales lors de la
célébration de la victoire de Stalingrad
jeudi dernier ont pour héros
l'exaltation d'un patriotisme agressif
alors soyons forts sachons résister oui
c'est un prédateur à l'extérieur de chez
frontières comme à l'intérieur de ses
frontières le peuple russe comporte
aussi son lot d'opposant à la guerre ce
qui ne veulent pas que leurs enfants se
fasse dévorer par le nationalisme ceux
qui ne veulent pas que la dictature
s’étende sur le monde sachant écouter
leur voix même s'il est encore faible et
réprimé Tolstoï faut conclure chers
collègues
Tolstoï a écrit que la vérité doit
s'imposer sans violence je regrette que
le dimmir Poutine est fait mentir cette
maxime mais j'espère qu'elle s'imposera
demain et que la justice et les droits
du peuple chrétien seront rétablis le
courage de l'Ukraine nous oblige
le courage de l'Ukraine nous oblige
madame gloire à l'Ukraine est au
président Pierre Laurent pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
la résolution que nous discutons arriva
à un moment crucial pour l'avenir du
conflit et pour celui de la paix
mondiale hier le secrétaire général de
l'ONU s'est alarmé je le cite que le
monde se dirige les yeux grands ouverts
vers une guerre plus large encore
mettant en garde contre les risques
d'escalade allons-nous entendre chers
collègues cette mise en garde il y a un
an l'agression militaire déclenchée par
Vladimir Poutine a plongé dans l'horreur
le peuple craignant et signer le retour
d'une guerre inhumaine au cœur de
l'Europe le bilan est d'ores et déjà
effroyable probablement plus de 300 000
victimes tuées ou blessés un pays
durablement meurtri des millions de
réfugiés de déplacés en termes Vladimir
Poutine croyait gagner la guerre en un
éclair la résistance de l'Ukraine et
départ la France et l'OTAN a changé la
donne
face à cette résistance qu'il
n'attendait pas VLAN Poutine a choisi le
pire toujours plus de guerre de crimes
de destruction de violation des droits
humains dont roulement forcé de jeunes
Russes sans compter le chantage
plusieurs fois brandi de la menace
nucléaire ce choix du pire a provoqué en
riposte en armement massif de l'Ukraine
un an plus tard malgré cet effrayant
bilan des moyens colossaux engagés de
part et d'autre et une ligne de front
globalement figée depuis des mois la
guerre ne s'apaise pas mais semble au
contraire à l'aube d'une nouvelle
escalade et cela en dépit du constat
dressé par le général Mac Millet chef
d'état-major des armées des États-Unis
le 9 novembre 2022 et Simon je cite il
doit y avoir une reconnaissance mutuelle
que la victoire n'est probablement pas
réalisable par des moyens militaires et
qu'il faut donc se tourner vers d'autres
moyens
j'entends aussitôt la critique admettre
admettre ce constat ce serait ainsi être
indifférent au drame ukrainien ou pire
se montrer complices de Vladimir Poutine
le président de la République lui-même
Emmanuel Macron a été confronté à cette
accusation larvée quand il a tenté de
maintenir ouverte la porte du
négociation sommet alors de rentrer dans
le rang des partisans de l'escalade
guerrière non chers collègues affirmait
notre soutien à l'Ukraine contre
l'agression militaire de la Fédération
de Russie dénoncer les crimes de
Vladimir Poutine exiger le retrait des
troupes russes et le respect de la
souveraineté de l'Ukraine et des
militairement et humanitairement
l'Ukraine à se défendre et à protéger sa
population
c'est indispensable comme nous le disons
depuis le premier jour de la guerre mais
cela de loi allait de père avec
l'impératif de prévenir une guerre
généralisée
et aller de pair avec une mobilisation
internationale de tous les instants pour
stopper le conflit pour explorer toutes
les voix capables de remettre les
belligérants à la table de négociation
en vue du retour à la paix et à la
sécurité mutuelle abandonner l'objectif
de la paix au sol profit de l'escalade
militaire
s'établiquée devant la perspective d'une
guerre longue et durable toujours plus
destructrice une guerre aux limites
inconnue chaque jour plus proche d'un
basculement conséquences un calculable
ce travail est urgentissime chers
collègues ne voyons nous pas s'accumuler
les vents mauvais d'une guerre toujours
plus large la Russie ne recule devant
rien pour envoyer la jeunesse russe à la
boucherie face à lui le surarmement des
pays de l'OTAN s'accélèrent dans des
proportions inédites les ventes d'armes
à l'international des États-Unis ont
dépassé les 200 milliards de dollars
inondales inondant l'Europe d'armes
toujours plus sophistiquée les
dirigeants polonais pas à proprement
parler des figures de la démocratie ont
augmenté le budget militaire de 9
milliards de d'euros en 2015 à 97
milliards en 2023 à grands coups
d'équipement américain
les surenchères nationalistes et les
réécritures de l'histoire se propage
partout et ont tous sens excitant les
haines des peuples au même moment ne
voyons nous pas excusez-moi nous voyons
nous rien de tout cela des périls
encourues européens ayant traversé deux
guerres mondiales avons-nous perdu la
mémoire voilà pourquoi chers collègues
nous ne voterons pas la résolution qui
nous est proposée elle énonce des
rappels de principes que nous défendons
nous-mêmes face à l'agression criminelle
de la Russie mais elle ne propose face à
ce drame qu'un seul chemin de fête
l'escalade militaire clairement
revendiquée par l'auteur de cette
proposition de résolution Claude malurey
c'est le sens de la linea 31
autrement dit après les chars lourds
porteurs d'obus à uranium ou appauvri
des avions de chasse demain des missiles
et à chaque grand nouveau des soldats
formateurs de l'OTAN directement engagés
la résolution donne en fait le feu vert
aux franchissement futur de toutes les
lignes rouges et surtout elle fait
l'impasse sur tout appel à une
initiative de négociation et de paix ce
n'est pas un oubli c'est un choix celui
de la guerre comme seul chemin possible
oubliant la leçon de tous les conflits
récents cette résolution est une
occasion manquée je conclus d'une phrase
celle de faire rimer solidarité avec
l'Ukraine et mobilisation pour une
solution de paix c'est cette double
exigence qui exprimera notre vote contre
merci la parole est à Madame Nadia solo
pour le groupe Union centriste pour 4
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre Monsieur l'Ambassadeur mes
chers collègues depuis un an les
auditions menées par le groupe d'amitié
franc sukraine que je préside ne parle
ni d'échange culturels ni de partenariat
économique les auditions que nous menons
sont des récits d'horreur de souffrance
et de terreur des récits de courage et
de résilience à chaque entretien nous
promettons de porter des messages je
remercie donc Claude malurey qui me
donne aujourd'hui l'occasion de le faire
une tribune qui ne sera pas la mienne
mais celle de ceux qui souffrent et nous
appellent au secours ce sera aussi la
tribune d'un groupe d'amitié qui n'a
jamais relâché ses efforts
le 23 mars 2022 nous étions une
vingtaine devant l'ambassade de Russie à
Paris nous portions un message simple
exigeant le respect des termes de la
Convention de Genève signé par la
Fédération de Russie nous demandions
d'urgence des corridors humanitaires
pour les populations civiles nous
portions les signatures de 170 d'entre
vous sénateurs de France nous n'avons
pas été reçus traités avec le plus grand
des mépris le 7 février 2023 nous
exigeons de nouveau le respect des
règles essentielles du droit humanitaire
international le respect des populations
civiles le traitement loyal des
prisonniers de guerre le libre accès aux
organisations humanitaires
internationales et tout particulièrement
à la Croix Rouge le 2 novembre 2022 nous
avons auditionné celle que l'on appelle
les fans d'Azov dont les époux épèrent
les fils ont défendu Mario Paul jusqu'à
la limite de leur force retenue
désormais dans des endroits tenus
secrets torturés privés de nourriture et
de soins ils sont sans contact avec leur
famille que cette résolution leur prouve
que nous ne les oublions pas et que nous
partageons les preuves de cette
inhumaine angoisse le 29 octobre 2022
nous recevions madame madvichu prix
Nobel de la Paix avocate qui dirige le
Centre pour les libertés civiles elle
recueille des témoignages pour
documenter les crimes de guerre on ne
documente pas seulement les violations
des Conventions de Genève
explique-t-elle en documente la
souffrance humaine chaque jour hélas
elle entend le pire nous devons lui
promettre que ces dizaines de milliers
de récits ne seront ni vains ni perdu et
qu'un tribunal international dédié
rendra sa justice le 19 avril 2022 les
responsables de l'UNICEF témoignaient
des souffrances des enfants en temps de
guerre en Ukraine tout particulièrement
les enlèvements massifs d'enfants vers
la Russie déjà ne faisait plus de doute
même si leur décompte manque encore de
précision nous devons par cette
résolution les dénoncer vigoureusement à
cette occasion des chiffres nous ont été
rappelés en 1914
90% des victimes de la guerre étaient
militaires 10% étaient civiles de nos
jours la proportion s'est inversée et
désormais dans un conflit où l'un des
deux belligérants cibles
intentionnellement les populations
civiles le nombre de femmes d'enfants et
de vieillards parmi les victimes est un
tolérable par cette résolution chers
collègues dénonçons une dérive inhumaine
je voudrais aussi avoir une pensée pour
nos collègues députés de la Rada
d'Ukraine qui travaille chaque jour et
sans relâche parfois sous les attaques
des bombes par exemple oud milabou et
mystère qui au lendemain de l'agression
du 24 février témoignée par visio en
gilet par balle demander des casques et
supplier l'Europe de fermer le ciel
voici quelques-unes des voix que je
porte au nom du groupe d'amitié chaque
jour de guerre est un jour de trop à la
gare de Kiev un grand nombre de jeunes
gens chaque jour partent pour le front
et une file d'ambulance récupère les
blessés c'est d'une tristesse infinie
nous souhaitons tous que cette guerre
cesse au plus vite mais aussi notre rôle
et notre devoir d'exiger tout de suite
le respect des valeurs essentielles de
la France pays des droits de l'homme
enfin je dois vous dire chers collègues
au fil des auditions mon oreille
rusophone se familiarise avec le
craignant un mot revient dans chaque
phrase et j'ai fini par le comprendre
pitrimka petrinka le soutien l'Ukraine a
besoin de notre soutien de notre soutien
sans faille à chaque instant le
Président stefanchouk nous a dit la
semaine dernière la culture japonais une
année de notre vie et bien mais vous
avez aussi changé oui nous avons changé
nous avons appris le sens du mot soutien
je vous remercie merci
alors la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Louis Masson pour 3 minutes chers
collègues
monsieur Masson je passe la parole à
Monsieur le Président Ruquier
monsieur Masson je vous remercie de
d'aller un peu plus vite merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues
je voterai contre ce projet de
résolution pour trois raisons
premièrement on organisant un blocus
économique contre la Russie et en
fournissant des armes ainsi qu'une aide
financière l'Ukraine les pays de l'Union
européenne et de l'OTAN sont devenus des
kobelligérants notre boycotte du gaz du
pétrole et des matières premières russes
est ainsi la cause de l'inflation et de
la crise économique que nous subissons
nous nous sommes donc pénalisés
nous-mêmes
deuxièmement on ne peut pas faire de
reproches à la Russie si dans le même
temps on laisse faire et même en
cautionne une agression encore plus
scandaleuse contre un autre pays
or le temps et l'Union européenne n'ont
rien fait lorsque l'Arménie a été
attaquée par les deux dictateurs
d'Azerbaïdjan et de Turquie pire on est
même allé jusqu'à doubler nos achats de
produits pétroliers à l'Azerbaïdjan ce
qui ne peut qu'encourager sa politique
d'agression
quant à la Turquie nous soutenons un
pays dont le dictateur se réjouit du
premier génocide contre les Arméniens et
qui a actuellement une politique
doublement génocidaire d'une part contre
lecture contre les Kurdes et d'autre
part contre les Arméniens si c'était la
Russie qui avait attaqué l'Arménie
l'OTAN et l'Union européenne aurait
réagi très vieux heureusement c'est bien
la preuve que l'OTAN a des arrières
pensées
enfin troisièmement nous sommes
actuellement dans la même situation
qu'elle avait de la Première Guerre
mondiale
à l'époque l'Allemagne n'était pas la
seule responsable de cette guerre car
les pays de l'Entente soutenaient la
Serbie et les terroristes cerveau
bosniaques qui ont assassiné l'archiduc
d'Autriche aujourd'hui la guerre en
Ukraine est en apparence liée à
l'agression de la Russie mais elle
résulte aussi de l'extension vers l'est
de l'OTAN et de l'Union européenne ce
qui conduit à encercler littéralement la
Russie les États-Unis n'ont jamais
accepté que l'Union soviétique puisse
installer des fusées à Cuba pourquoi
voudrait-on que les Russes acceptent
aujourd'hui d'être encerclé par l'OTAN
en voulant mettre la Russie à genoux le
temps prend le risque irresponsable d'un
conflit nucléaire tout comme la première
guerre mondiale cela pourrait nous faire
des dizaines de millions de morts aussi
bien d'un côté que de l'autre ceci étant
je suis je compatis avec la situation
aussi bien
de tous les Russes qui sont morts dans
cette guerre que de tous les Ukrainiens
mais je crois qu'il y a une lourde
responsabilité des pays occidentaux dans
cette affaire
merci la parole est à monsieur le
Président Jean-Claude roquet pour le
groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et sociales européens pour
5 minutes chers collègues un président
de monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous sommes en quelques jours
dans la date tragique de l'anniversaire
de la question portée par la Fédération
de Russie contre l'Ukraine cela fait un
effet bientôt à l'encre le Vladimir
Poutine
projet
d'impérialisme russe cela fait bientôt
un an qui replonge le monde dans les as
de la guerre en faisant croire à qui
veut entendre qu'au fond c'est
l'Occident l'agresseur face à cela
depuis des mois sans se résigner sans
finir les Ukrainiens restent debout
malgré la durée des combats dans
l'Ukraine malgré le déluge des bombes
qui frappent la population civile du
soccer de Kiev les ukrainiens et le
président Deski forcent le respect
le courage du peuple ukrainien n'est
plus à démontré il a désormais d'exemple
il s'écrira certainement dans l'histoire
boutique
symboles de les résistance acharnée ce
sont aussi des villes martyrs oui
monsieur Stéphane souk l'a rappelé lors
de notre hémicycle la semaine dernière
le site l'ennemi cruel sève la mort à la
destruction les Ukrainiens pétraient
cher le prix de la liberté par
conséquent le devoir de continuer à les
soutenir d'autant plus que nous agissons
aussi pour notre propre sécurité celle
de l'Europe et même au-delà comme la
très justement soulignée le président de
la République de la radar
ukrainienne l'Ukraine est devenu le
bouclier qui protège l'Europe et
l'ensemble du monde civilisé c'est une
c'est évidente de plus en plus fortement
la France et la communauté
internationale
il ne s'agit plus seulement de la
souveraineté d'un territoire envahi mais
bien d'un combat est collectif pour
établir les règles élémentaires de
l'ordre mondial même Israël jusqu'à la
retrait interroge depuis quelques jours
sa position tant le macabre des sièges
stratégique russe
bouleverse tous les équilibres
stratégiques dans ces conditions comme
le souligne à proposition de résolution
l'aide fournit à l'Ukraine doit être
accentué sur tous les fronts le front de
500 bien entendu en cet égard à mon
groupe se réjouit de voir arriver un
dixième paquet de mesures annoncé par
Bruxelles
pourvu que les affaiblissent l'industrie
des défenses russes
l'Union européenne doit toutefois se
pencher sur la question des
contournements qui affectent la réalité
d'une partie des sanctions quant au from
militaire la nécessité d'un effort
constant de livraison d'armes forts
ukrainiennes apparaît désormais
incontournable on peut le regretter
certains balles d'escalade les inversons
pas les rôles comme le fait si bien la
propagande russe jusque sur le continent
africain qui a gravi les marches de
l'horreur sous couvert d'une prétendue
opération spéciale à ce stade nous
savons qu'une clé d'indiquer la victoire
ukrainienne réside à la défense
antérienne mon gros battant de la France
qui a construit à consolider à défenses
solaires de l'Ukraine en complément de
soutien militaire américain significatif
bien entendu nous souscrivons à la
réserve qui consiste à préserver le
territoire russe des attaques des
missiles quant au front diplomatique
doit-on y croire encore nous avons
espéré que la veille du en février 2022
en 20 aujourd'hui hélas des négociations
de paix semblent ne semble pas
envisageable en effet déçu pour ne pas
dire humilier par son insucius militaire
enfermé dans une spirale paranoïaque
Vladimir le redoutable continue
d'organiser son armée dans une logique
de guerre un changement de général le
développement du LA MONDIALE
mobilisation et une quasi installation
dans son pays d'un pouvoir parallèle
représenté par la limite par les
ministres pris goji s'agissant de ces
mercenaires mon groupe souscrit allié de
cibler Wagner comment réaliser un
terroriste leur brutalité et sans
équivoque et on doit par ailleurs
s'inquiéter
de la développement sur le continent
africain et chers collègue signataire de
la proposition de loi de Claude malurer
les membres du rdrc la botteran toute
logique nous espérons apporter notre
modeste contribution au combat du monde
libre
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est à Monsieur Pascal azizard pour le
groupe les républicains pour 12 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
sur un sujet à faire étrangères et avant
de vous parler de l'Ukraine je voudrais
que nous ayons une pensée forte et aussi
exprimée notre solidarité notre soutien
aux populations syriennes et turques
victimes du séisme de ce week en
depuis un an l'actualité internationale
est dominée par cette guerre en Ukraine
à l'initiative de la Russie Russie
membre permanent du Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies membres de l'OSCE et
du Conseil de l'Europe notamment autant
dire que la Russie n'ignore rien des
principes du droit international et
pourtant les autorités les autorités
russes n'ont pas hésité à déclencher une
violente opération militaire contre un
État souverain l'Ukraine baptisé
pudiquement opération spéciale elle est
en fait une vraie guerre d'invasion
visant à la conquête de territoire au
remplacement d'autorité légale
démocratiquement élue à la mise au pas
du peuple ukrainien et à la main mise
sur l'économie et l'agriculture
ce coup de force illégal nous ne pouvons
pas l'accepter ce serait la fin de
l'ordre international et le retour à la
loi du plus fort dans ce contexte
l'initiative de notre collègue Claude
Malhuret est à salué et ça adresse un
message fort et clair du Sénat nous
avons d'ailleurs reçu si même il y a
quelques jours une importante
d'élégation ukrainienne conduite par le
président de la Rada précédé d'ailleurs
par un entretien avec le ministre de la
Défense
ukrainien quel que soit les causes
invoquées par les autorités russes à la
pluie de leur politique belliqueuse il
reste que dans ce conflit il y a tout de
même un agresseur et un agressé
l'Ukraine est un État souverain dont
l'intégrité territoriale doit être
respectée et les règles du droit
international ont été volontairement
ignorés par la Russie
ce conflit brutal décime les civils
Ukrainiens détruit des installations
vitales rasent des villes et aboutit à
l'occupation illégale de territoires
pire encore une partie des opérations et
sous-traitée à des mercenaires recrutés
dans des prisons russes ainsi qu'à des
forces tchétchen dont les méthodes sont
destinées à terroriser en déplacement en
Ukraine avec le président Larcher et
quelques collègues nous avons vu in situ
cette sale guerre dans laquelle des
exactions sont commises quotidiennement
contre des civils sans compter les
missiles qui cible les habitations des
contes devront être rendus par les
responsables de ces actions criminelles
contraires à toutes les lois y compris
contraire aux lois de la guerre c'est le
sens de cette proposition de résolution
le conflit à ravivé la peur sur le
continent européen qui après deux
guerres mondiales se croyaient à l'abri
la bulle de prospérité économique
l'économie européenne est désormais
victime des effets collatéraux de cette
guerre est fait collatéraux qui
s'étendent jusqu'à la rive sud de la
Méditerranée et même au-delà l'Europe
aussi dû faire face à un flot historique
de réfugiés ainsi je le crois les
Européens ont tort de considérer les
questions stratégiques comme secondaire
quand d'autres États renforcés leurs
outils de puissance et diversifiés leur
mode d'action les inquiétudes les plus
fortes s'expriment chez les voisins
immédiats de la Russie ou la confiance
vous le savez n'a jamais véritablement
régner ce fut la neutralité contrainte
de la Finlande également le rideau de
fer qui ajouta l'Europe qui a amputa
pardon l'Europe et son flan est un
certain nombre de pays traumatisés par
cette expérience ont souhaité rejoindre
l'Union européenne et le temps
les vagues successives d'élargissement
ont porté l'Union européenne et l'OTAN
aux frontières russes avec des
conséquences géopolitiques peut être mal
anticipée même n'y est parfois par
certains il s'agissait en effet de
l'adhésion à un projet politique et
économique européen d'un côté et à une
alliance militaire menée par les
États-Unis de l'autre cette
occidentalisation rapide de territoire
longtemps liés à la Russie leur passage
sous protection américaine n'est pas un
changement anodin mais à l'époque on
croyait fermement peut-être à tort à la
fin de l'histoire entre guillemets et à
l'affaiblissement durable de la Russie
la politique européenne de partenariats
oriental conçu au départ comme la
création d'un cercle d'amis je cite est
devenu plus ambigu pour les Russes
l'Union européenne travaille dans leur
arrière cours pour l'Union européenne au
contraire les pays du Partenariat
oriental sont des pays souverains c'est
exact et qui compare librement les
offres et leur liberté de choix doit
être respectée au final le projet
d'accord entre l'Union européenne et
l'Ukraine les velléités ukrainiennes
d'adhérer à l'OTAN ont donné lieu à la
réactivation de tension avec la Russie
et à l'enchaînement de fait tragique au
cours de cette période je crois que les
Occidentaux ont peut-être mal
appréhendés les ressorts du
fonctionnement russe d'abord le puissant
complexe obsidional historique qui
aujourd'hui tourne à l'obsession voire à
la paranoïa surtout pour des dirigeants
formés dans l'appareil sécuritaire
soviétique tout administratif russe
s'appuie sur ce sentiment d'encerclement
de marginalisation qui justifie les
investissements massifs dans le domaine
de la défense les actions militaires à
l'extérieur de plus les Russes sont le
sentiment avec les largissements
successifs d'un abus de faiblesse commis
au moment où leur pays était au plus bas
alors aujourd'hui ou allons-nous quels
sont nos objectifs et des l'Ukraine à se
défendre récupérer la Crimée changer le
régime à Moscou ces objectifs sont-ils
partagés par tous les soutiens à
l'Ukraine et en mesure-t-on bien toutes
les conséquences toutes ces questions
mériteraient une réponse claire des
autorités françaises et européennes car
l'émotion si légitime soit-elle ne peut
pas et ne peut en aucun cas être notre
boussole beaucoup de choses ont été
faites en matière de dénonciation de la
Russie de sanctions et d'aide à
l'Ukraine un nouveau paquet de sanctions
contre Moscou étant une bonne chose nous
avons aussi livré des équipements
individuels des munitions du
renseignement du matériel de guerre tels
que des systèmes d'artillerie le débat
récent porte sur l'envoi de chars léger
ou lourd en quelle quantité cette
évolution doctrinale comporte nombre de
difficultés d'ordre stratégiques
opérationnelle et politique et déjà les
autorités ukrainiennes réclament des
avions on peut le comprendre le
président Macron a annonce que rien
n'est interdit par principe on peut
l'entendre aussi mais c'est une telle
montée en puissance se confirmer il
serait de plus en plus délicat de se
déclarer extérieur au conflit et à être
considéré comme tel il faut bien le
mesurer malgré ces mesures et les
dernières annonces nous ne voyons pas
d'inflexion des autorités russes au
contraire nous assistons à une
radicalisation des discours à
l'émergence sur la scène politique de
personnages inquiétants comme il l'a
fait la Seconde Guerre mondiale ou plus
récemment en Tchétchénie le pouvoir
russe mise sur le stock sur le temps
long pardon dans une guerre de
saturation une guerre d'attrition grâce
aux immenses stocks accumulées et au peu
de café des vies de ces soldats surtout
lorsqu'ils viennent des confins de la
fédération et enfin l'économie russe
résiste au FMI et ce même effet mi
prévoit pour 2024 une croissance pour la
Russie supérieure à celle de la zone
euro comprennent qui pourra nos
sanctions et nos moyens militaires
contingentés même technologiquement
supérieur suffiront-ils à changer la
donne jusqu'où sommes-nous prêts à aller
face à une puissance dotée nous sommes
désormais sur un terrain glissant les
opinions publiques commencent à
s'interroger y compris aux États-Unis la
question du contrôle des armes livrées
et du bon usage des aides est aussi un
sujet
par ailleurs cette situation
malheureusement fait le jeu de la Chine
et des États-Unis je constate
aujourd'hui combien il est judicieux
pour les Chinois d'avoir mis en place
des outils financiers alternatifs
permettant d'échapper au sanctions
occidentales et qui peuvent être
proposés à leurs alliés comme la Russie
de plus les entreprises russes se
tournent vers le One pour leur contrat
et cette pratique pourrait durablement
sans créer en janvier 2023 la Russie
annonçait que la relance du marché des
changes allait permettre de privilégier
le One pour se dès de l'arriver je cite
ces rapprochements Russo chinois dans de
nombreux domaines doivent donc là aussi
nous interpeller l'Europe pourrait se
trouver cornerisée dans deux grands axes
Chine Russie d'une part et États-Unis et
leurs alliés anglo-saxons d'autre part
la Chine se garde bien de soutenir
ouvertement l'invasion russe sans pour
autant la désavouer non plus et déjà à
travers conflit et la politique de
sanctions qui en découlent la division
du monde prend corps entre le camp
occidental et le reste du monde autour
d'un pôle Russo chinois tandis que l'ONU
est de plus en plus marginalisé en
raison des sanctions les difficultés
financières de la Russie ces besoins en
bien équipement haute technologie la
rapproche encore plus de la Chine quant
aux États-Unis après la période de Trump
assez désastreuse pour leur image
internationale l'évacuation difficile
non concertée de Kaboul ils ont amorcé
un réengagement en Europe malgré la
primauté accordée à la zone
Indo-Pacifique la faveur de la guerre en
Ukraine dans toute l'Europe les achats
sur étagères de matériel américain se
multiplient à l'avenir à la ferme
l'avenir de la bit2 européenne et
notamment française est en jeu
si les Européens à juste titre ont
montré une certaine unité une vraie
fermeté face à la Russie je ne suis pas
sûr à ce stade qu'ils aient gagné en
crédibilité dans la mesure où la plupart
d'entre eux considèrent que seul l'OTAN
et les États-Unis sont en capacité de
les protéger l'Europe puissance est
encore loin et Washington n'a aucun
intérêt à une trop grande autonomie
politique et militaire européenne alors
pour la France le chemin de crête est
étroit tout en gardant ouvert les canaux
de dialogue il semble important de
maintenir une ligne de fermeté vis-à-vis
de l'agresseur russe de poursuivre le
soutien au peuple
ukrainien mais également de porter une
attention plus soutenue aux actions
indirectes menées par la Russie en
Afrique francophone et dont nous sommes
la cible le moment venu il faudra aussi
aider en lien avec nos partenaires à la
reconstruction de
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier caddy pour le groupe
Union centriste pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues voilà près
d'un an la Fédération de Russie a décidé
d'envahir l'Ukraine mes premiers mots
seront pour la population
ukrainienne et sa résistance admirable
face à la barbarie de l'envahisseur
l'occasion nous est donnée avec cette
résolution transpartisane du président
maluré de réaffirmer le soutien du Sénat
envers l'Ukraine une semaine après avoir
ovationné ici le président de la Rada
ukrainienne
Anne de Kiev reine des Francs il y a
près de 1000 ans aurait toute sa place
parmi les femmes illustres qui ornent le
jardin du Luxembourg en érigeant sa
statue le Sénat pourrait rappeler ainsi
les liens indissolubles qui unissent
l'Ukraine à la France
ce soutien à l'Ukraine nous avions voulu
l'apporter avec le président malurey en
nous rendant à Kiev le 20 avril dernier
quelques jours après que les Russes
soient chassés de ses environs à
irpinnes Boro Janka boutcha ville
martyrs ont commis des massacres nous
avions découvert un cadre indescriptible
de ruines ou même les statues avaient
reçu une balle dans la tête
à bout de chat avec des enfants nous
avions planté des arbres pour rappeler
que l'espérance le bien et nos valeurs
l'emporteront au final
ses enfants Ukrainiens connaissent
désormais les abris la terreur des
bombardements
leur regard vide et triste me hante je
suis revenu du crâne avec la conviction
que tout doit être entrepris pour
arrêter cette guerre en détruisant les
infrastructures énergétiques de
nombreuses villes l'armée russe utilise
l'hiver et le froid comme une arme pour
faire céder la population les frappes
incessantes sur les immeubles les
hôpitaux ou encore les écoles et les
crèches constituent une véritable
stratégie de la terreur à l'encontre des
Ukrainiens d'où déplorons des dizaines
de milliers de civils morts ou blessés
la cruauté de Monsieur Poutine peine à
trouver ses limites un crime impuni est
un crime récompensé selon la formule de
mélèm Khalaf un député libanais qui
occupe son parlement depuis 20 jours
aujourd'hui avec sa collègue Najat
Saliba afin d'exiger l'élection du
président libanais
que prévoit le gouvernement et l'Union
européenne pour que les crimes de guerre
et les crimes contre l'humanité commis
par la Fédération de Russie soit jugée
et leurs auteurs punis depuis un an la
France se tient aux côtés de l'Ukraine
avec ses partenaires européens dès le
début du conflit des trains de sanctions
étaient décidés
à faire la guerre à ce jour l'Union
européenne a décidé de neuf-35ions
intégrant également la Biélorussie et
l'Iran pour l'aide qu'ils apportent à la
Russie ce dont nous félicitons fidèle à
sa devise unie dans la diversité l'Union
européenne a démontré la volonté d'agir
ensemble pour relever les défis la
Pologne a affirmé un rôle de leadership
avec les États baltes et la Roumanie
pour mobiliser l'Union européenne et ne
pas tergiverser
l'aide de l'Union européenne que ce soit
en matière de protection civile par son
soutien force armé ukrainienne a
contribué à soutenir la résistance
héroïque du peuple ukrainien face à son
envahisseur soyons en fiers nous pouvons
également participer à la reconstruction
économique ukrainienne en facilitant le
retour des investisseurs il faudrait
pour cela Monsieur le Ministre changer
la couleur rouge à l'ouest du pays de la
carte conseil en voyageur
pour accompagner la l'Ukraine dans sa
lutte pour sa liberté et sa défense et
la défense de nos valeurs nous devons
aller plus loin dans nos livraisons
d'armes le président annonçait vouloir
aider à renforcer les systèmes
anti-aériens en Ukraine pouvez-vous nous
préciser si le sujet a été évoqué lors
du sommet Union européenne
Ukraine le 3 février dernier comme vous
l'aurez compris le groupe Union
centriste votera pour cette résolution
je vous remercie merci
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier bèche
est un ministre délégué chargé du
Commerce extérieur de l'attractivité et
des Français de l'étranger
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs la
proposition de résolution aujourd'hui
débattue de votre assemblée porte sur un
enjeu particulièrement important pour la
France et pour l'avenir du continent
européen l'agression russe de l'Ukraine
déclenché le 24 février peu après 8 ans
de conflits larvé et d'ingérence
militaire russe en Ukraine a vu le
retour de la guerre interétatique de
haute intensité en Europe impliquant un
état doté de l'arme nucléaire
par cet acte d'une extrême gravité la
Russie affranchi toutes les limites et
violer les règles régissant les
relations internationales depuis 1945
notamment les principes fondateurs de la
Charte des Nations Unies que sont la
souveraineté des États et le respect de
leur intégrité territoriale cette
invasion les objectifs mis en avant pour
Moscou pour justifier sa prétendue
opération militaire spéciale et
l'annexion illégale de quatre régions
ukrainiennes à l'issue de simulacre de
référendum démontre si besoin était la
volonté russe de nier l'existence de
l'Ukraine en tant que nation
indépendante est libre de choisir son
destin
alors que nous approchons du premier
anniversaire de cette agression barbare
injustifiée et injustifiable force est
de constater que la Russie n'a en rien
abandonné ses objectifs et qu'elle
cherche à soumettre la nation
ukrainienne par la force militaire
malgré les revers sérieux qu'elle a
connu retrait de la région de craie de
Kiev au printemps dernier
contre-offensive
ukrainienne réussie dans la région de
carquif en septembre abandon de Kerson
en novembre seul Capital régional
qu'elle avait conquise et prétendait à
avoir annexé la Russie poursuit son
agression avec une violence sans limite
elle exerce aujourd'hui une pression
extrême dans le don-basse ou elle a
réussi à progresser dans le secteur de
backmouth sans la moindre considération
pour ses propres soldats qu'elle utilise
comme de la chair à canon
seule la Russie est responsable de la
poursuite des hostilités en Ukraine
alors que l'Ukraine a montré sa
disponibilité à travailler à une paix
juste et durable à travers le plan de
paix en 10 points présenté par le
président les zona ski que la France
soutient
la Russie poursuit par ailleurs sa
stratégie lâche et cynique visant à
détruire les infrastructures
essentielles de l'Ukraine afin de mettre
le pays à genoux depuis le début du mois
d'octobre des salles de successives de
missiles et de drones vise les
infrastructures électriques gazières ou
de distribution d'eau nécessaire à la
survie de la population civile pendant
l'hiver la dernière salle a eu lieu le
26 janvier le jour où la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Madame Catherine colonnat visiter la
ville de dessin qui a été touchée
l'objectif russe est clair désorganiser
l'arrière ukrainien et se met la terreur
parmi la population pour infléchir la
résistance de l'Ukraine à l'agression ce
ciblage systématique de la population
civile la ministre l'a rappelé cela ne
s'apparente pas à faire la guerre
c'est faire des crimes de guerre dans
ces circonstances la résistance dont
font preuve depuis près d'une année
l'armée et la population ukrainienne
force notre admiration
en conjuguant la bravoure et la
détermination de ces soldats aux
équipements sophistiqués que nous lui
avons livré l'Ukraine a montré qu'elle
était capable de résister et de
repousser l'envahisseur russe nous le
redisons la Russie ne parviendra pas à
briser la résistance du peuple ukrainien
celui-ci se bat pour sa liberté et dans
cette lutte l'Ukraine n'est pas seul
nous nous tenons à ses côtés et nous
continuerons de le faire pour l'aider à
retrouver son intégrité territoriale et
sa souveraineté c'est ce message de
soutien indéfectible qu'apportait aux
autorités ukrainiennes la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Madame Catherine Colonna lors de sa
visite à Odessa le 26 janvier c'est ce
même message que le Président de la
République a transmis au président de la
Rada et au ministre ukrainien de la
défense la semaine dernière
dès le début de cette agression que nous
avons cherché à éviter jusqu'au
dernières heures la France s'est placée
du côté du respect du droit et de la
liberté en apportant son plein soutien à
l'Ukraine dans l'exercice de sa légitime
défense
ce conflit nous le savons ne se règlera
pas intégralement par les armes il
faudra à un moment se mettre autour de
la table et négocier mais ce moment
n'est pas venu et ce sera à l'Ukraine et
à l'Ukraine seul de décider quand et à
quel condition elle souhaitera le faire
nous avons donc consenti un effort
considérable de livraison et
d'équipements militaires et nous
continuerons de le faire afin de mettre
l'Ukraine en position de force pour
recouvrer son intégrité territoriale la
décision du Président de la République
de livrer des chars légers début janvier
à initier une dynamique positive parmi
nos partenaires et ouvert la voie la
livraison de matériels cruciaux pour les
forces armées ukrainiennes
de nouvelles annonces françaises ont été
faites par le Président de la République
et le ministre des armées à l'occasion
de la visite du ministre ukrainien de la
Défense à Paris le 31 janvier nous
allons fournir à l'Ukraine 12 canons
César qui s'ajouteront au 18 déjà fourni
nous allons poursuivre notre soutien
dans le domaine entière fournitures
d'une batterie asmt conjointement avec
l'Italie d'un radar GM20 et de missiles
pour les batteries anti-aériennes
crottes
essentiel pour protéger la population
civile ukrainienne des frappes russes
nous travaillons également à des
solutions pour fournir à l'Ukraine des
munitions de nouveaux véhicules blindés
du carburant et pour assurer le maintien
en conditions opérationnelles des
équipements livrés et assurer un
ravitaillement en carburant
nous avons participé au lancement de la
mission militaire européenne eux-mêmes
et le ministre Sébastien Lecornu a
annoncé que nous formerions 2000 soldats
Ukrainiens sur le territoire français
d'ici l'été tandis que 150 militaires
français se rendront à la fin du mois en
Pologne pour former jusqu'à 600 soldats
ukrainien par mois nous sommes également
l'un des plus importants contributeurs à
la facilité européenne de paix qui
apporte un soutien en équipement
militaire létal inédit au niveau
européen et nous avons mis en place un
fond bilatéral que vous avez porté à 200
millions d'euros pour que l'Ukraine
puisse se fournir en matériel auprès de
notre base industrielle et de
technologie de défense
la France est donc comme les Ukrainiens
le disent même un soutien de premier
plan à la fois par l'ampleur des
montants mobilisés par la fiabilité du
matériel qui a fourni et par larabilité
avec laquelle elle parvient à répondre
aux besoins exprimés par pièce
mais notre aide ne se limite évidemment
pas au domaine militaire nous consacrons
au total plus de 2 milliards d'euros à
l'aide civile à l'Ukraine face aux
conséquences humanitaires dramatiques
des frappes russes contre les
infrastructures ukrainiennes nous avons
organisé le 13 décembre à Paris la
conférence solidaire du peuple ukrainien
afin d'aider l'Ukraine à passer l'hiver
47 états et 24 organisations
internationales ont répondu présent et
ont promis plus d'un milliard d'euros
d'aide d'urgence qu'il s'agisse de dons
matériels ou de financement dans les
domaines de l'énergie de l'eau de la
santé de l'alimentation et des
transports la France a pour sa part
annoncé un effort total de 125 millions
d'euros pour les seuls mois de l'hiver
l'intégralité de cette somme aura été
engagée au 15 février ce qui correspond
rapporté à la fenêtre calendaire à
l'effort humanitaire le plus important
jamais déployé par notre pays
c'était Dora un impact concret sur la
vie de milliers d'ukrainien victimes de
la stratégie russe visant à faire de
l'hiver une arme de guerre pour vous
donner des exemples concrets 63
générateurs haute puissance sont en
train d'être livrés en Ukraine en plus
des 100 déjà livrés début décembre ainsi
que 5 millions d'ampoules LED qui
permettront de réaliser d'importantes
économies d'énergie
l'effort total dans le secteur
humanitaire s'élève à 200 millions
d'euros en faveur de l'Ukraine et des
pays limitrophes notre centre de crise
et de soutien à mener plus de 40
opérations pour un total de 2700 tonnes
d'aide acheminées
nous avons également apporté un soutien
précieux aux juridictions ukrainiennes
et internationales en matière de lutte
contre l'impunité c'est l'une de nos
priorités car il n'y aura pas de paix
durable en Ukraine sans justice nous
avons apporté un soutien aux enquêtes
ukrainiennes de la CPI et de regius afin
de contribuer à la collecte des preuves
de crimes de guerre nous avons aussi
envoyé deux équipes de médecins légistes
et de gendarmes de l'IRCGN à bousta en
avril et dans la région de kerki fin
septembre et fait don de deux
laboratoires d'analyses ADN nous
participons réflexion sur la poursuite
du crime d'agression qui a initié
l'Ukraine dans le cadre du corps groupe
qui s'est réuni à Prague les 26 et 27
janvier dernier et nous accueillerons la
prochaine réunion de ce groupe à
Strasbourg fin mars
pour apporter une aide financière à
l'Ukraine à titre bilatéral et au niveau
européen et participer à l'effort de
reconstruction à plus long terme qui se
structure sous l'égide de la plateforme
de coordination des donateurs mise en
place à Bruxelles par le G7 parmi nos 2
milliards d'euros d'aide nous avons
croyé un pré budgétaire direct de 400
millions violet FD et fléchi 1,2
milliards vers des garanties à l'export
qui bénéficie à de larges spectre de
projet économiques essentiel à la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine un exemple
concret celui de la plateforme numérique
de la modélisation de la reconstruction
de l'aublast de tchernilif porté par
trois entreprises françaises
enfin nous poursuivons nos efforts
visant à accroître les difficultés de la
Russie à financer sa guerre d'agression
par l'adoption de nouvelles sanctions
celles-ci sont une preuve de l'unité
européenne les États membres ont réagi
avec une rapidité sans précédent en
adoptant les premières mesures 48 heures
après l'invasion russe nous avons depuis
lors adopté 9 paquets de sanctions
sectorielles comme individuels au niveau
européen mais aussi bâti des coalitions
avec nos partenaires du G7 et
l'Australie afin de plafonner le prix du
pétrole russe ces sanctions ciblées et
proportionnées portent leurs fruits
comme en atteste la baisse du prix du
pétrole brut russe depuis la mise en
œuvre
de ce dispositif de plafonnement dans la
perspective de l'adoption d'un dixième
paquet de sanctions dans les prochaines
semaines la France prépare de nouvelles
initiatives visant à entraver le
fonctionnement de l'économie de guerre
russes et à sanctionner ses responsables
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
vous le voyez le soutien de la France
est total il engage l'ensemble de l'État
français mais mobilise au-delà les
collectivités les ONG les entreprises et
je le sais parfaitement votre hôte
assemblée le soutien que nous apportons
à l'Ukraine c'est notre devoir
c'est notre honneur et ce sont
évidemment nos valeurs les valeurs d'une
république qui s'est bâtie sur la
défense du droit et de ses libertés le
vote de la proposition de résolution
aujourd'hui soumis à votre examen le
confirmera j'en suis persuadé ensemble
nous tenons debout sans faiblir au côté
de l'Ukraine et nous continuerons aussi
longtemps qu'il le faudra à le faire je
vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors nous
allons procéder au vote sur la
proposition de résolution la Conférence
des Présidents a décidé que les
interventions des orateurs valaient
explication de vote j'ai été saisie
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe Les Indépendants il va être
procédé au scrutin public d'un
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne
non c'est bon
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin clos
alors je vais donner les résultats du
scrutin merci nombre de votants donc 344
nombre de suffrages exprimés 340 pour
l'adoption 324 contre 16 le Sénat a
adopté
je vais suspendre la séance quelques
instants pour permettre à chacun de
s'installer pour l'examen du prochain
point à l'ordre du jour la séance est
suspendue